la surpêche v2 les maires à un rythme
beaucoup plus rapide qu'on ne le croyait
ce constat accablant et celui que vient
de publier l'éminent chercheur daniel
pauly de l'université de la colombie
britannique
il a passé 15 ans à refaire le portrait
mondiale des pêches
sa conclusion on capture en moyenne de
50 à 60% plus de poissons que ne
l'affirment la haye fao l'organisation
des nations unies pour l'alimentation et
l'agriculture
il ya une sous-estimation mais quand on
la voit clairement quand on voit
d'autres personnes confirmées ça c'est
quand même une bonne impression qu on a
du travail qu'on fait le problème c'est
que la haye fao se base uniquement sur
les données volontaire de ses pays
membres
beaucoup trop de pêche ne sont pas
comptabilisés un exemple la pêche
sportive aux bahamas
elle prélève chaque année des quantités
importantes de grands poissons méprise
du bar à maçon deux fois demi donc de
160% de les prises rapporté
l'équipe du professeur pauli a aussi
estimé des captures provenant des pêches
artisanales comme celle du pacifique sud
par exemple
donc si on examine les pêches domestique
dans ce petit pays du pacifique sud
c'est 80% des deux reprises qu'ils sont
qui sont pas enregistrés c'est pour ça
qu'on a mais pourcentage énorme de de
pêche non enregistrés le chercheur a
aussi tenu compte des prises
accidentelles qui totaliserait quelque
30 millions de tonnes chaque année
si l'on veut reconstruire les stocks
daniel paul il affirme qu'il faut à tout
prix réduire les activités pêche sans un
virage majeur dit il nos océans
continueront de se vider et le drame
pourrait bien se jouer en silence ici
gilbert béjart radio canada québec